[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg willkommen zum
Nachrichtenüberblick an diesem
Silvesterabend an meiner Seite ist für
den Sport wieder Norbert König guten
Abend der erste deutsche Papst seit fast
500 Jahren ist tot
Trauer um Benedikt den 16 der frühere
Papst stirbt im Alter von 95 Jahren im
Vatikan Politikerinnen und Theologen aus
aller Welt würdigen den Deutschen als
bescheidenen und streitbaren geistlichen
[Musik]
Neujahrsansprache in Krisenzeiten
Kanzler Scholz ruft die Menschen in
Deutschland zu Zusammenhalt und
Zuversicht auf
und Party quer durch alle Zeitzonen
Australien feiert bereits das neue Jahr
in Deutschland steigt die Vorfreude auf
wir beginnen mit dem Blick nach Rom um
9:34 Uhr heute morgen ist benedikt der
16 gestorben etwa eine Stunde später
veröffentlichte der Vatikan die
Todesnachricht auf der ganzen Welt
trauern Katholiken um ihr ehemaliges
Kirchenoberhaupt
vor eineinhalb Stunden bei der
traditionellen Andacht zum Jahresende im
Petersdom würdigte Papst franziskus
seinen Vorgänger
mit erinnern wir uns an seine so edle
und so sanfte Person und wir empfinden
Dankbarkeit gegenüber Gott dass er der
Kirche und der Welt Benedikt den 16
geschenkt hat so die Worte von Papst
franziskus fragen wir Andreas Postel in
Rom dieser Tod kam ja nicht überraschend
bereits um die Weihnachtsfeiertage hatte
sich der Gesundheitszustand des
emeritierten Papstes doch dramatisch
verschlechtert und heute wurde bekannt
dass es bereits am Mittwoch ja die
letzte Ölung erhalten hatte an dem Tag
als Papst franziskus dann auch die
Gläubigen weltweit dazu aufgerufen hatte
für den schwer erkrankten Papst Benedikt
den 16 zu beten
im Laufe des Tages hat sich die
Nachricht natürlich hier in Rom herum
gesprochen unter den Gläubigen und
vielen Touristen die jetzt zum
Jahreswechsel hier in Rom sind es wurde
dann merklich ruhiger auch die
Vatikanische Museen wurden am Nachmittag
geschlossen und auch der Petersplatz
wurde geräumt in Vorbereitung auf die
Messe die hier zum Abend zum
Jahreswechsel im Petersdom abgehalten
wurde und die haben dann sehr viele
Gläubige im Gebet bereits vom imitierten
Papst Abschied nehmen können danke schön
für den Moment Andreas Postel wir reden
nachher noch mal
wir sind Papst so feierte die
Bild-Zeitung 2005 die Wahl von Kardinal
Josef Ratzinger zum ersten deutschen
Papst seit fast 500 Jahren er galt als
brillanter Theologe und intellektueller
mit seinem Rücktritt schrieb er
Geschichte polarisiert hat er immer auch
wegen seines Umgangs mit dem sexuellen
Missbrauch in der katholischen Kirche
Andreas Postel Blick zurück
er werde ja nun bald vor dem endgültigen
Richter seines Lebens stehen als sein
treuer Begleiter Georg Gentz war ein
Anfang 2022 diese Zeilen zu
Missbrauchskandal vorträgt weil es der
hochbetagte Benedikt im eritus selbst
gesundheitlich nicht mehr kann klingt es
wie ein geistiges Testament
dunkle Schatten hatte das Münchner
missbrauchsgutachten auf das Wirken
Josef Ratzingers geworfen die
Vergangenheit holte ihn einen langen
nach seinem Rückzug als Papst Benedikt
der 16 dem wohl mutigsten Schritt seines
Pontifikats das am 19 April 2005 begann
[Applaus]
kardinalem Ratingen
Josef Ratzinger wird der 265 Papst der
Kirchengeschichte
ein Deutscher auf dem Stuhl Petri
geboren 1927 in Marktl am Inn
in Freising beginnt seine geistliche
Laufbahn hier wird er 1951 zum Priester
geweiht gemeinsam mit seinem Bruder
Georg
[Musik]
als Theologieprofessor macht der
schnellkarriere wird später Erzbischof
von München und Freising
der Gang von hier in die Ewige Stadt sei
ihm nach eigenen Worten schwergefallen
Johannes Paul II macht ihn zum perfekten
der Glaubenskongregation auch als Papst
bleibt der Theologieprofessor und doch
kann er begeistern Jubel beim
Weltjugendtag in Köln und auch bei
seiner Reise in die bayerische Heimat
eine theologische Vorlesung in
Regensburg jedoch wird zur schweren
diplomatischen Krise ein Zitat über den
Islam empört die muslimische Welt
auch die Begnadigung der Bischöfe der
Pius-Bruderschaft wird zum Skandal als
Holocaustleugnung in Williamsons bekannt
werden der Papst gesteht Fehler ein
fühlt sich missverstanden
während seines Pontifikats sitzt er
stets auf Aussöhnung und Dialog mit dem
Judentum besucht das ehemalige
Vernichtungslager in Auschwitz
in Israel die Gedenkstätte jagferschem
er verurteilte jede Leugnung oder
Relativierung des Holocaust
zu einer der größten Herausforderungen
wird der Umgang mit sexualisierter
Gewalt in der katholischen Kirche
systemisches Versagen zeichnet sich ab
weltweit Benedikt empfindet tiefes
Mitgefühl Charme und Bedauern über jeden
einzelnen Fall doch das geht viel nicht
weit genug zu lange habe die Kirche
weggesehen mehr Täter als Opfer
geschützt
seinen überraschenden Rücktritt im
Februar 2013 begründete er mit
schwindenden Kräften Gerüchte über
Intrigen im Vatikan die war die
leaksaffäre all das ließ er zurück als
er sich am 28 Februar 2013 per
Hubschrauber nach castellgerndorf begab
ich bin einfach nur noch ein Pilger der
die letzte Phase seiner Pilgerreise auf
dieser Erde antritt sagte er
ja
mit diesen Worten verabschiedete sich
benedikt der 16 von den Gläubigen denn
der Mann der 1 Josef Ratzinger aus
Marktl am war blieb bis zu seinem
irdischen Ende im vatikanischen Exil
hochbetagt und gebrechlich reist er noch
einmal nach Deutschland um Abschied zu
nehmen von seinem älteren Bruder Georg
und von seiner bayerischen Heimat damit
ging für Joseph Ratzinger vor seinem
eigenen Abschied noch ein Herzenswunsch
in Erfüllung
Jürgen Erbacher ist bei mir ZDF
vatikanexperte guten Abend Erbacher was
bleibt von diesem Papst ja der Rücktritt
der war historisch der hat das Papstamt
nachhaltig verändert enzeralisiert etwas
geerdet das Papstamt viele werden sie
erinnern an Josef Ratzinger als einen
großen Theologen der versucht hat in
einer zunehmenden säkularisierten Welt
die Frage nach Gott wach zu halten als
Papst ist er wie ein Missionar durch
Europa gereist und hat versucht eine
Wertedebatte anzustoßen weil er immer
der Meinung war Europa allein nur aus
der Wirtschaft heraus wird nicht
funktionieren es hat aber auch viele
geben die denken an den Papst der
versucht hat das katholische Profil der
Kirche zu schärfen sie stärker an der
Tradition auszurichten und damit ist
aber ganz vielen angeeckt und hat auch
viel Kritik hervorgerufen ja sie sagen
ist er war auch umstritten gerade weil
er sich gegen die Modernisierung der
Kirche gestemmt habe auch die was er zur
Aufarbeitung des missbrauchskandals
beigetragen hat wird unterschiedlich
gesehen
dachten sie das ja also Benedikt war
eher ein Bewahrer als ein Reformer wenn
er an Veränderungen gedacht hat dann
ging es eher um den geistliche
Erneuerung und weniger um eine
strukturelle Reform und das ist auch das
Problem beim Thema Missbrauch er hat
zwar viele Regeln verschärft da hat sich
mit Opfern getroffen und hat auch
öffentlich um Vergebung gebeten aber er
ist nicht an die strukturellen Wurzeln
ran die dieses Übel und Vertuschung
möglich gemacht haben wenn man insgesamt
auf das Pontifikat blickt muss man sagen
er wurde mit 78 Jahren gewählt das heißt
die Kardinäle wollten einen
übergangspaps nach einem turbulenten
langen Pontifikat unter Johannes Paul
dem zweiten mit vielen Reisen große
Events sollte jemand die Kirche wieder
in etwas ruhigere Gewässer führen
allerdings in seinem Pontifikat sind die
Probleme die über Jahrzehnte sich
aufgestaut haben brennglasartig deutlich
geworden und das hat dann am Ende zu
seinem Rücktritt geführt und zur Wahl
eines Papstes ganz anderen Typs
franziskus
ganz herzlichen Dank für diese
Einschätzung Jürgen Erbacher ZDF
vatikanexperte bitteschön sein Glaube
sein Intellekt seine Weisheit und seine
menschliche Bescheidenheit haben mich
immer tief beeindruckt so würde ich der
Bundespräsident Steinmeier den früheren
Papst auf der ganzen Welt wurde Benedikt
Tod von Anteilnahme und Trauer begleitet
vor allem in seiner Heimat in Bayern
aber auch dort gibt es kritische Stimmen
Barbara Luke
stille Trauer kleine Gesten heute im
bayerischen Marktl am Inn für den großen
Sohn der Stadt vor dem Portal seiner
taufküche hängt die Fahne auf Halbmast
innen feiern sie Nachmittag sein Requiem
für ihren Josef Aloisius Ratzinger denn
irgendwie war er das immer einer von
ihnen
sehr traurig darüber
weil es doch einer war von uns ein
herausragender Theologe steht außer
Frage aber im Herzen ist es sehr einfach
geblieben
mit Trauer geläutert die katholische
Kirche in Deutschland heute den
verstorbenen Papst
Kondolenzbücher liegen aus in Gottes
Güte und beim Herzlichkeit wird er auf
immer Heimat finden schreibt der
Vorsitzende der Deutschen
Bischofskonferenz und erinnert an den
großen Theologen und Denker er war
bereit mutig einzustehen für das
Evangelium ob gelegen oder ungelegen und
deshalb konnte es nicht verwundern dass
manche seiner Reden auch Anstoß erregt
haben
eine zentrale Trauerfeier ist nicht
geplant stattdessen heute in vielen
Kirchen die hier im Münchner frauendom
Erinnerungen Gedenken an einen Theologen
Professor Bischof und Papst der immer
auch seine Kritiker hatte
er war letztlich doch ein sehr
konservativer Theologe der die
reformimpulse des Zweiten Vatikanischen
Konzils wieder zurückgedrängt hat und
damit hat er der katholischen Kirche der
Weltkirche ein sehr schweres Erbe
hinterlassen in Marktl am Inn aber rufen
sie ihm heute mit bayerischem Herzen vor
allem eines nach sage herzlich Vergelt's
Gott wir alles was er hier gewirkt hat
als unser Papa im eritus
in diesem Gedanken ziehen Sie hier am
Abend ins neue Jahr
die Totenfeier für den ehemaligen Papst
in Rom soll am Donnerstag sein Andreas
Postel was genau ist geplant und was
passiert bis dahin
so ungewöhnlich der Rücktritt von Papst
Benedikt dem 16 war so wenig klar war
auch wie was passiert wenn ein
emeritierter Papst stirbt das ist heute
im Laufe des Tages etwas deutlicher
geworden der vatikaner hat mitgeteilt
dass am 2 Januar also am zweiten Tag des
neuen Jahres der Leichnam Benedikt im
Petersdom aufgebaut wird damit die
Gläubigen sich auch Gebühren von ihm
verabschieden können und am 5 am
Donnerstag wird es dann die Trauerfeier
geben auf dem Petersplatz die wird auch
Papst franziskus dann leiten und Papst
Benedikt der imitierte Papst hat sich
gewünscht dass diese
Trauerfeierlichkeiten sehr schlicht
stattfinden sollen und diesem Wunsch
wird man ihn auch erfüllen danke für
diese Information Andreas
um 19 Uhr senden wir ein ZDF Spezial zum
Tod von Benedikt dem 16 außerdem finden
Sie in unserer App und auf ZDF heute
eine ausführliche Dokumentation mit den
wichtigsten Stationen seines Lebens
ein Appell führt Zusammenhalt und
Zuversicht das ist die Botschaft der
Neujahrsansprache von Olaf Scholz der
Angriffskrieg Russlands auf die Ukraine
Stelle das Land auf eine harte Probe
sagte der Bundeskanzler Deutschland sei
aber stark und er wünsche sich dass die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger ihren Weg treu
bleiben Daniel Kunzen fast zusammen
letzte Vorbereitung vor den letzten
Worten eines Jahres des schwer war so
der Kanzler aber auch Anlass zu
Zuversicht gäbe weil es gezeigt habe
dass Deutschland innovativ sei und
zusammenhalte ein Land das mit Tatkraft
und Tempo an einer guten sicheren
Zukunft arbeitet ein Land das sich
unterhagt gerade in schweren Zeiten ein
Land in dem wir niemanden zurücklassen
egal ob in der Stadt oder auf dem Land
ob alt oder jung ob gut situiert oder
weniger wohlhabend ob hier geboren oder
erst später hierher gekommen bei seinem
imperialistischen Angriffskrieg so
Scholz habe sich Putin massiv
verkalkuliert er habe die Ukraine nicht
in den Tagen überrannt den Westen nicht
gespalten sondern geeint und wir in
Deutschland sind nicht eingeknickt als
uns Russland im Sommer den Gashand zu
gedreht hat weil wir uns nicht erpressen
lassen stattdessen habe Deutschland
trotz fordernder zeitenwände
überwältigen Hilfsbereitschaft gezeigt
wir fühlen mit den Ukrainerinnen und
Ukrainern die selbst am Tagen wie heute
keine Ruhe haben vor den russischen
Bomben und Raketen und wir alle spüren
die Folgen dieses Kriegs auch in unserem
Alltag beim Einkaufen im Supermarkt an
der Tankstelle oder wenn wir die Strom
oder Gasrechnung bezahlen mit
entlastungspaketen habe seine Regierung
der Teuerung entgegengewirkt zu neuer
folgten nun weitere Entlastungen bei
Wohngeld etwa und Kindergeld unser
Zusammenhalt ist unser größtes Pfund
darum wünsche ich uns am Beginn dieses
neuen Jahres eines bleiben wir dem Weg
treu den wir im vergangenen Jahr
eingeschlagen haben gehen wir in mutig
weiter ein Appell der ein wenig so klang
als er ja auch an die eigene
Ampelkoalition gerichtet
acht Minuten ist die Neujahrsansprache
des Bundeskanzlers sie sehen Sie direkt
nach diesen Nachrichten der ukrainische
Präsident selenski bedankte sich bei
Olaf Scholz auf Deutsch mit einer
Twitter-Nachricht für Waffenlieferungen
für den Schutz für mehr als eine Million
Ukrainerinnen und Ukraine und für
finanzielle und technische Hilfe auch am
Silvestertag setzte Russland wie
erwartet seine massiven Luftangriffe
fort Einschläge werden aus Kiew gemeldet
von dort berichtet eine Brühl
als der Luftalarm ertönt über Kia
verheißt das nichts Gutes
diese Bilder sollen russische Raketen im
Anflug auf die Ukraine zeigen am letzten
Tag dieses ersten Kriegsjahres es sind
mehrere Angriffswellen und diesmal
gelten sie nicht nur der Infrastruktur
Trümmerteile fallen auf ein Wohngebiet
die Druckwelle hat mich und meinen Mann
an die Wand geschleudert wir sind auf
dem Boden im Korridor gefallen dann
haben wir gehört wie das Fensterglas
zersplitterte und dann kam Explosion
nach Explosion
es gibt verletzte auch einen toten fast
drei Stunden dauert der Angriff auf die
ukrainische Hauptstadt
im Zentrum von Kiew schlägt eine
russische Rakete vor einem Hotel ein was
die Menschen hier besonders schockt ist
der Zeitpunkt des Angriffs
wenigstens an diesem Feiertag den Tag
den die ganze Welt feiert haben wir auf
ein Wunder gehofft
stattdessen sitzt du im Korridor und du
weißt überhaupt nicht ob du morgen noch
lebst
sie versuchen mit aller Kraft uns
Neujahr zu verderben aber das schaffen
sie nicht wir werden die Überhand
behalten und siegen
tot und Zerstörung es ist ein bitterer
Jahresausklang für die Menschen in Kiew
und wir fragen noch mal nach bei Anne
Brühl in Kiew wie erleben Sie dieses
Silvester
bedrückend hier im Zentrum von Kiew
haben wir am Nachmittag 8 schwere
Explosionen gehört dieses Hotel vor dem
die russische Rakete eingeschlagen ist
das ist ja ganz in der Nähe das waren
diesmal eben nicht nur Angriffe auf die
Infrastruktur und besonders den
Zeitpunkt dieser Angriffe empfinden die
Menschen hier als sehr perfide die
Ukraine feiert heute Neujahr das große
Familienfest das hat heute abend
begonnen so ähnlich wie bei uns äh heute
Heiligabend und natürlich ist den
Menschen diese Botschaft dieser massiven
Angriffe an diesem besonderen Tag klar
nämlich Angst und Schrecken unter der
Zivilbevölkerung zu verbreiten
Eindrücke live aus Kiew danke Anne
Frieden das ist wohl der sehnlichste
Wunsch fürs kommende Jahr hierzulande
laufen die letzten Vorbereitungen für
den Jahreswechsel vor allem auch bei
Polizei und Feuerwehr eines ist klar
frieren wird heute wohl kaum einer
silvia blessmann hat mehr
ein Silvesterknaller ohne echtes
Feuerwerk steigt mit der zdf-party am
Brandenburger Tor
2500 Tickets sind vergeben Vorfreude
beim Musikern und Gästen das ist schon
viele Jahre mein Traum gewesen einmal am
Brandenburger Tor zu stehen und mit
allen gemeinsam
anzustoßen und reinzurutschen tausende
sind bei den milden Temperaturen auf den
Straßen viele auch mit sorgen zum
Jahreswechsel am meisten der Krieg sage
ich mal aber natürlich auch
Energiekrise bzw diese ganze
Umweltgeschichte 23 hoffe ich einfach
auch weil ein gutes Jahr dass wir alle
gesund bleiben das ist Frieden gibt die
Berliner rettungskräfte rechnen mit
einer ereignisreichen langen Nacht auch
die Polizei hat aufgestockt und werden
mit zusätzlichen 1000 Einsatzkräften im
Einsatz sein wir werden uns vor allem
auf Bereiche konzentrieren die ja lokale
Brennpunkte darstellen wir werden
präsent sein und dort wo es erforderlich
ist die Strafverfahren einleiten drei
Böller Verbotszonen sind eingerichtet
wie hier am Alexanderplatz um
Verletzungsgefahren einzudämmen dennoch
rechnet auch die Feuerwehr mit hunderten
zusätzlichen Einsätzen wir werden
geplant ab 19 Uhr in den Ausnahmezustand
Silvester gehen und haben uns personell
so aufgestellt dass wir nahezu eine ver
nach der Anzahl von Mitarbeitenden und
auch ehrenamtlichen Kräften im Dienst
haben ein tolles Fest soll es werden
hier am Brandenburger Tor mit
friedlicher Botschaft hinaus in die Welt
ja und jetzt sind die beiden Moderatoren
zugeschaltet Andrea Kiewel und Johannes
B Kerner was sind eure Höhepunkte heute
abend hallo guten Abend liebe Barbara
Liebe ZuschauerInnen liebe Zuschauer und
ja es ist die letzte Nacht des Jahres
und ich glaube nach diesem Jahr dann
gibt es etwas was uns alle vereint der
Wunsch nach zumindest letzten guten
Stunden einer großen großen Party wir
sind live am Brandenburger Tor aktuell
noch ohne Jacke das Jahr verabschiedet
sich frühlingshaft aber wir sind nicht
allein hallo Berlin
also Kiwi schon auf betriebsstemperatur
wir melden uns zu Füßen es Brandenburger
Tors diesmal von der Ostseite spielen
zum ersten Mal so dass man die quadriger
von vorne sehen kann und sind
musikalisch wirklich perfekt vorbereitet
mit nationalen und internationalen Stars
von der Münchner Freiheit über DJ Bobo
und Sascha bist hin zu einer Band die
den Song komponiert hat der vielleicht
der größte Song ist der jemals in
Deutschland komponiert worden ist die
Scorpions live am Brandenburger Tor wind
of change in einer bisher nie da gewesen
lösenden Version und der Song der hat ja
schon mal was bewegt vielleicht klappt
das noch mal also ab viertel nach acht
melden wir uns hier willkommen 2023
einen guten Rutsch für dich liebe
Barbara viele Grüße an die Kolleginnen
und Kollegen und Sie liebe zuschauen und
Zuschauer viertel nach acht wir haben
ein Date Dankeschön nach Berlin danke
euch beiden und alles Gute
wir müssen uns noch gut viereinhalb
Stunden bis zum Jahreswechsel gedulden
aber es gibt Zeitzonen auf unserem
Globus die sind deutlich früher dran
dort hat das Jahr 2023 schon begonnen
Nina kuscheln zeigt uns wo und wie die
Menschen dort Silvester feiern
Happy New Year das konnten sich als
einer der ersten die Neuseeländer
wünschen dort wo im letzten Jahr noch
wegen Corona die meisten Events abgesagt
worden waren schossen um 12 Uhr mittags
unserer Zeit erstmals wieder Böller in
den Himmel wie hier in Auckland am Sky
Tower das Feuerwerk in über 300 Metern
Höhe
zwei Stunden später im australischen
Sydney dann eines der spektakulärsten
Feuerwerke auf der Welt 8 Tonnen
Feuerwerkskörper für fast 4 Millionen
Euro bestaunt von einer Millionen
Menschen zwischen Haba Bridge und
Opernhaus im Mittelpunkt der Show ein
Regenbogen Wasserfall denn das Motto in
diesem Jahr lautet Vielfalt und
Inklusion
wie hier in Tokio begrüßen die Menschen
in Japan das neue Jahr traditionell
bedächtiger ohne Böller dafür mit einem
Besuch im Tempel oder schreien und nach
108 Glocken Schlägen die um genau
Mitternacht Enden ist dann auch hier
bereits das neue Jahr eingeläutet
vor zwei Stunden dann war es in Hongkong
soweit
[Musik]
tausende Menschen bestaunten das pompöse
Feuerwerk und hießen das neue Jahr 2023
bereits willkommen
ja aber Sport gab es heute auch neues
springen Generalprobe Fürst Neujahrs
springen und da ist Karl Geiger ziemlich
früh gelandet ja aber vielleicht folgt
trotzdem ein neujahrsknaller in
Garmisch-Partenkirchen das ko-duell mit
dem Japaner nikkaido soll jedenfalls
beim zweiten Wettkampf der
Vierschanzentournee kein Problem werden
für Karl Geiger trotz Platz 30 in der
Qualifikation
schon in der Anlaufspur sucht Geiger die
Balance ein durchwachsener Sprung nur
119 Meter im Wettkampf soll es hier in
Partenkirchen besser laufen die Form von
von Oberstdorf die passt natürlich die
Stabilität die muss man jetzt von den
letzten Wochen ein bisschen Betracht
ziehen das ist noch nicht zu 100% stabil
ist aber ich weiß grundsätzlich trotzdem
was ich zu tun habe morgen zählt zehn
deutsche sind ein neuer dabei Beste
dsv-springer an Silvester der 22-Jährige
Philipp Reim und 126 einhalb Meter als
Qualifikation 9 ganz vorne David
Kubatzki der Tournee dritte landet nach
140 einhalb Metern Tag ist Bestweite und
Kampfansage an den Gesamtführenden
kranuth
und er folgt dem Lockruf des Geldes
fußball-superstar Cristiano Ronaldo
wechselt nach Saudi-Arabien zu all Nassa
ja das Gehalt angeblich 200 Millionen
Euro
für Cristiano Ronaldo ist es ein Staat
in ein neues Leben mit einer neuen
gehaltsdimension der Vertrag von CR7 bei
alnassa läuft bis 2025 der Schritt in
die sportliche Bedeutungslosigkeit wird
ihm angeblich mit 200 Millionen Euro im
Jahr versüßt es wäre der lukrativste
Vertrag der Fußballgeschichte nach
seinem unrühmlichen Abgang bei
Manchester United lässt der fünfmalige
Weltfußballer seine Karriere in einem
Land ausklingen das laut Amnesty
International die Menschenrechte
missachtet
das war's
das neue Jahr beginnt sehr mild mit
Regen im Norden und etwas Sonne im Süden
Details hat gleich Christa Augen hier
geht es weiter mit der Neujahrsansprache
des Bundeskanzlers danach folgt das ZDF
Spezial und um 0 Uhr bringt sie dann
Kasten Rücker auf den neuesten
nachrichtenstand im Namen des gesamten
nachrichtenteams sage ich vielen Dank
und wünsche Ihnen alles Gute und einen
guten Rutsch bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
ja guten Abend heute am letzten Tag des
Jahres und der war außergewöhnlich
bisher lag die höchste jemals gemessene
silvestertemperatur bei 17 Grad in
Mülheim Baden-Württemberg 1961 heute
wurden dort 20 Grad gemessen und in
Wielenbach in Bayern sogar knapp 21 Grad
dazu etliche neue monatsrekorde im
ganzen Land mit 13 bis 19 Grad was für
eine Luftmasse dementsprechend mild ist
mit 15 bis 9 Grad auch die Nacht nur im
Südosten geht es auf acht bis zwei Grad
hinab hier ist es auch klar am Wasser
bildet sich Nebel im Norden und
Nordwesten gibt es die Wolken und den
Regen der Wind schwächt sich etwas ab
bleibt an der Küste und auf den Bergen
aber ein Thema und das auch morgen noch
dazu weiter im Norden die Wolken etwas
Regen der sich nachmittags von Westen
her verstärkt im Süden und Südosten ist
der Neujahrstag freundlich und trocken
und dazu wieder sehr mild mit 10 bis 17
Grad am Oberrhein sind wieder 20 Grad
möglich zum Start in die neue Woche gibt
es im Westen viel Regen ab Dienstag wird
es dann langsam mal wieder etwas kühler
und das war es von uns im alten Jahr das
ganze wetterteam wünscht Ihnen ein
frohes neues Jahr tschüss